Salut. Est-ce que vous savez pourquoi le "Docteur Who" s'appelle le "Docteur Who"?
Alors que dans la série, jamais personne ne l'appelle le "Docteur Who" d'ailleurs.
La série a été crée en 1963, donc bien avant ce que pense la plupart des gens.
Ça a cartonné jusqu'en 1996 et après ça a été repris à partir de 2005.
Il y a eu plus de 800 épisodes et une douzaine d'acteurs qui ont interprétés le Docteur.
"LE DOCTEUR!"
Le Docteur qui s'appelle dans la série, "Le Docteur"
Il n'a pas d'autres noms que "Le Docteur"
Au départ ce qui était prévu dans la série, c'est qu'il s'appelle le "Docteur Who"
et que tout le monde l'appelle le "Docteur Who" puisque personne ne savait vraiment qui c'etait.
C'était ça l'idée de départ de Cecil Edwin Webber, le scénariste.
L'idée, elle a été mise de côté mais ils en font un clin d’œil dans la série
Bon, déjà parce que ça a donné le titre de la série
Mais si vous regardez la série en VO (Version Originale)
Vous verrez qu'ils se sont faits un petit trip puis qu’a chaque fois que le Docteur se présente
il dit "Je suis le Docteur" et la réponse en face répond "Docteur Qui ?"
Ce qui en anglais donne.... Bah, vous avez compris
Comme prévu cette été, il y'a une vidéo tous les deux jours sur un truc un petit peu léger.
Histoire de s'amuser cet été, donc ce sera jusqu'au 30 août alors
rendez-vous après-demain. Pensez a liker la vidéo et abonnez-vous si c'est pas déjà fait. Tchao !